hi and welcome to serverless migration
station where we show google cloud users
one step they can take to modernize
their serverless apps
i'm wesley joined by my colleague martin
and our little friend porter to take you
from point a to point b
as a long time app engine developer
you're probably aware
of using its default database the app
engine data store
via its ndb client library to make user
apps more portable
the next generation app engine service
has moved away from bundled services
like datastore
since datastore has matured into its own
product cloud datastore
we're here to help you take the key step
of migrating from app engine's ndv
to cloud ndb so your app can basically
use the same ndb code but accessing
cloud datastore instead
my app uses datastore quite a bit so i'm
interested in this
how do i get started with this migration
wes well in the previous video for
module 1 we migrated our baseline web
app 2 ndb data store app to flask
a popular framework in the python
community today we pick up right where
module 1 left off
a flask ndb datastore app and we're
going to migrate that to a flask
cloud ndb datastore app ah yes i
remember that migration but i forgot
where
the module 1 code is can you point me to
it again
definitely martin so go to the migration
module video
and clone it or download the zip file
its link is also in the video
description below
we'll start with the module 1 code
perform the ndb
migration steps and voila that will
result in the module 2 code
since this app uses only one app engine
service
after moving to cloud ndb you can easily
port your app to python 3
so the codelab features that bonus
migration that's why you'll also find a
pair of module two repo folders
one each for python two and three hold
on partner
let's do the cloud ndb migration first
so hit pause now to go get the module
one code
okay if you're ready let's walk you
through this migration
as in previous modules let's ensure we
have a working app before migrating
from your module 1 folder check you've
got flask in your lib folder
or run the pip install command if you
don't upload to app engine with gcloud
app deploy
then once it's live point a browser or
curl to it and confirm the outputs the
same from modules 0
and 1. next we're ready to migrate to
cloud ndb
this time starting with the config files
anytime you use a google cloud
client library in python 2 you need a
pair of third-party helper libraries
fortunately they're already on app
engine servers so do not add them to
requirements.txt
nor use pip install built-in libraries
like this
are declared in app.yaml here create a
new library section with grp cio and
setup tools
if your app's app.yaml has a library
section
add these helper libraries if they're
not already there
the good news is that third-party
packages are way easier in the next gen
where it's just requirements.txt
in the module one video we explained you
need to tell app engine
where to look for your self bundle or
copied third-party libraries
that's done in app engine config.py it's
also true of built-in third-party
libraries like grpcio and setup tools
but requires a different code snippet in
app engine config
where you reference them to live in the
setuptools.package resources working set
just like you see here this app engine
config can now handle both built-in
and copied third-party libraries so this
is probably pretty good boilerplate to
have for all of your python 2 app engine
apps
we mentioned earlier how third-party
package management is
way easier in python 3 and not even
having an app mission config file is
part of that
next are the 3rd party packages we do
need to copy our bundle in module 1
we created requirements.txt with a
single reference to flask
now add the cloud ndb library spelled
google cloud
ndb all lowercase with hyphens in
between
when making this video flask was on
version 112
and cloud ndb was on 180. since the repo
is actively maintained you may see newer
versions there
now delete any old lib folder you may
have and run the pip
install command to get those libraries
in there so we can upload to app engine
that's it for config let's jump into
main.py starting with the imports
it's a one for one swap to switch from
app engine ndb to cloud ndb
as with most google cloud client
libraries you need to create a client to
access the api
so that's the new line you see the best
news is that most of your ndb code stays
as is
the only difference is that it's more
idiomatic python
requiring use of the client's context
manager
if you're new to those it's just saying
that you need to acquire those resources
before you can use them
you'll typically see with statements
with files because you've got to be able
to open a file before you can read from
or write to it right
so add a new width block and put all of
your data
store calls inside like what you see
here everything else is the same
making this migration fairly painless
one more tip is that transactional tasks
isn't a feature in cloud ndb yet
meaning you can't create tasks only if
the transaction succeeds
in other words task queue calls won't
get rolled back
if the transaction fails only data store
operations
ignoring the readme all other source
files stay unchanged
index.html template file gcloud ignore
and really that's it so that's the
entire migration to cloud ndb
before we go back to the presentation
let's talk briefly about a python 3 port
the language updates you have to make
may be considerable
if there's any good news on the app
engine side it mostly involves deleting
stuff like deleting a bunch of lines
from app.yaml
deleting the lib folder and
apogenconfig.py file
our super simple app is already python23
compatible
so the only file that needs updating is
app.yaml
change the language version now that's
obvious nextgen app engine requires a
web framework that does its own routing
so you have three options here set all
script handlers to auto because the
framework does the routing now
two delete all script handlers because
if everything is auto they're all
meaningless right
or three replace handlers with an entry
point section
if you have specific startup
requirements read more about these
options in the docs
note i only said script handlers static
file handling stays as is
lastly i've already said third-party
package management in the next gen is
way simpler
allowing you to delete the library
section entirely
again the real work for your app is the
language update
okay back to the show wow
that was a pretty straightforward
migration wes i'm glad to see most user
code doesn't have to change
i have one question though what if i
have an older app
say a python 2.5 app the 2.5 runtime was
deprecated in 2013
and then it was completely shut down in
2017
uh when python 2.7 took over so my app's
been dead
ever since can i somehow bring it back
to life
ah the answer is yes martin but there is
a catch
you have to migrate from 2.5 to 2.7
and db to ndb first before applying the
migration we just discussed
check out these python25db docs as well
as the ndb migration guide to get
started
that's great are there docs for ndb too
well here are the links to app engine
ndb as well as its library repo
we'll also post them in the description
below thanks for those db
and ndb resources can we round out this
trifecta with the cloud
ndb docs and while you're looking that
up uh why is it so important to migrate
to cloud ndb anyway of course martin
here are its library and its docs links
as far as why it's important you know
that modernizing your app and making
them more portable is one goal of the
latest app engine platform
for python developers the key reason is
that cloud adb works in both
python 2 and 3 which means that once
you're on cloud ndb
you can finally upgrade your app to
python 3.
and with that you've crossed the
datastore finish line literally
this is the last of the required
migrations as far as the data store goes
it's not necessary to migrate further to
cloud datastore's native client library
nor cloud firestore unless you've got
specific reasons to do so
okay what would be some of the reasons
i'd consider those optional data store
migrations
well using the official cloud data store
client library
means moving away from everything you
know about ndb and how it works
the primary reason to do this is if you
have other apps that already use it for
example python 3
app engine apps or non-app engine apps
and you want to consolidate so that
you're not using two different client
libraries to talk to the same data store
it simplifies and reduces your
maintenance cost too
anyway if you want to look into it see
the module 3
code lab and video the next generation
of cloud data store is cloud firestorm
based on the name change you can
probably guess that it now has some
features from the firebase real-time
database and you'd be right
this migration is for those who must
have some of those firebase features for
their apps
check out module six if interested okay
so
if those other data store migrations are
optional uh where can i go
now yeah great question martin while
users should continue to migrate from
app engines
bundled services to standalone services
outside of app engine like cloud and db
what other app engine services and apis
are you using
if you use push task queues consider
migrating to cloud tasks
and see module 7 to get started if your
organization is consolidating apps into
containers for
flexibility cicd or consistency
consider migrating the cloud run if so
see modules
4 and 5. finally it goes without saying
that porting to python 3 should always
be a consideration since python 2 has
been sunset
we add new migration modules
periodically and most will have videos
too so keep checking back
cool what other migration resources do
you have
for cloud ndb well the best place to
look is in the docs for cloud ndb
especially its migration guide the code
in those docs has its own repo so here's
a link to that
and finally check out the last link that
points to migration samples contributed
by the community
on behalf of martin and porter this is
wesley chun thanks for tuning in to this
episode of serverless migration station
and allowing us to show you different
ways to modernize
your apps and we'll see you the next
time on another
serverless expeditions
you